is city skylines an easy game or a hard
game and this is a question which seems
to be so well simple at first but it's
something that I started to think about
as well because in the in the first
couple of episodes I used to say that
this was a very easy game and really
helped me along the way but then again
the developers themselves said that it
does bring many challenges and I en
again said that the game was terribly
easy and way too easy for that matter
and it's really hard to decide whether
this game is actually too easy or too
hard because it does mean that disaster
management that you used to have in
SimCity although I don't really miss
that because I was never too glad about
my city which I put so much labour and
love into and went to [ __ ] because of
some stupid Godzilla but that's that's
completely beside the point I feel like
this game is easy when you first look at
it it really helps you along the easy
and you know simple things but as soon
as you really want to start building a
extremely realistic and well-functioning
city it starts it starts to get harder
so I definitely think that this is an
easy game but you can give yourself a
challenge to set certain goals for
yourself now one goal but you can set
which is very accomplishing if you
actually do stuff with it is the traffic
management which is something that I am
going to do in this episode and as you
can see i'm removing all of those roads
over there because the issue that I had
with my city was even though I did kind
of plan the entire layout in a sense
that if it would grow and I would have
more traffic it would still be able to
take on all that traffic but nope that
didn't turn out to be that way so the
hague which is that little neighborhood
over there which still bears the name
but does not even exist anymore it is
now completely flattened by that
enormous highway that I'm going to
construct right now going into the
middle of my city so I have a highway
connection leading right to the downtown
area which does involve some major
changing of the city layout but I think
I'm pretty glad with it so far though it
is pretty hard to actually get all of
those ramps and stuff like that to
actually work well and look good and not
make the area too not so great and as
you can see the land
you around this area is dropping right
now so that is a shame of course but you
know sometimes you just have to
sacrifice certain things among above
certain other things and I definitely
think that traffic flow is much more
important that land for you obviously
this is just one stupid neighborhood
next to the downtown don't really care
about that too much now one thing that I
do care about is this industrial area
and oh my when traffic problems arise in
this game they are usually among the
industrial areas and you know you've got
all of these trucks going in and out of
the area and they need to load and the
animations are quite stupid because they
tend to disappear inside buildings not
to mention the floating people and stuff
like that but I i might showcase that
later on but yeah industrial areas are
very crowded with trucks and it's kind
of hard actually it's very much a
challenge to actually get these things
to work well without congestion so I'm
going to actually pay some attention to
how I'm going to manage that and at this
point because i'm actually commentating
this many episodes after this is
actually recorded because if you know me
i open up my game and I play for eight
hours and then I have to convince myself
to actually start rendering and making
those videos and though not necessarily
in that order of course and that means
that this video is released but well
probably a couple of days after I
recorded it actually so yeah but I
decided to just mess around with those
industrial areas to see what I could do
and I came up with this idea that I
would have highways leading into it and
as you can see this is just a small
industrial area and I decided to build a
roundabout over here and then have all
these one-way lanes around it which
essentially the entire industrial area
to incentive one big roundabout where
all the trucks have to go around to
their business literally speak in some
and that that's just the idea that I had
for that not really sure if it's working
too great but so far I haven't had too
many problems with that so at this point
most of the
problems with traffic or somewhat solve
but as you can see when I was checking
the traffic thingy there are still quite
some problems with them and I think the
issue is though and I'm not sure about
this but I feel like whether an area is
red or green it is all based on how many
cars it has / space and I'm pretty sure
about this it might also but I feel like
it might also be that it's red depending
on how fast the cars are driving but I
don't think this is the case and I would
almost kind of wish that this was the
case but something because sometimes you
have these areas where there are many
cars driving especially on the highways
but and they're not really stopping
anywhere there's no traffic jam it's
just kind of crowded it still shows as
red on the map and that is still kind of
annoying like nothing is actually wrong
with those things it's just something in
my brain saying hey that's red you need
to fix that but you cannot have that and
that road by the way I have no idea what
I was exactly planning with ours like
hey I can build some forest industry
let's try that so I tried that hooked it
up on the electricity and the water
system and then decided to do nothing
with that because um oh no way that was
actually farmland and at that point I
decided you know I'm going to turn this
in the street into for ministry because
for some reason the farm industry
doesn't pollute or anything like that so
I didn't want all that weird purple
gooey stuff from the ground so I'm just
decided to replace all that with
farmland
industry in fact is really a thing is
one thing that I do notice about this
game though the industry is kind of not
so realistic especially when you compare
it to the realism of the rest of the
city because I don't think that the
ground actually turns purple next to an
industrial area now of course Raj is
waiting for mods to pick down at this
fixed and at this point and that will
probably be some more to that fixed that
but it's not just that about it it's
also the fact that when you plays forest
in this industry stuff you actually get
a couple of threes and many big
buildings and I don't know exactly what
they're doing and where they're getting
their wood but for some reason that they
have like a couple of trees next to them
and son somehow they just produce tons
of wood each year and that just doesn't
seem like an entirely realistic thing
and I don't even know what these farm in
the streets are supposed to be but oh
well they work pretty well and they
don't pollute or anything so any spices
decided to do some stuff with that but I
might actually make a tutorial on how to
build these industrial complexes because
it is definitely a very complex thing to
build I need to stop doing that I'm very
sorry but yeah I'm not entirely happy
about the way that the industry works in
this game of course it's still really
great and I just love this game and I'm
often playing it to death right now but
you know there are just certain things
which you always be able to criticize I
suppose and one thing that I would
actually like to see but if this already
exists in the game then I'm really happy
about that and I didn't say anything
about this but so far I haven't actually
been able to get it even though I do
have the University and stuff like that
and it does seem like the education
levels in my city are pretty high one
thing that I always loved about
SimCity's the fact that you can get high
tech industry and so far I haven't
really seen it or my industry is
actually a high-tech but it still looks
like shitty industry and you know I
would love to have that I would love to
have all these software companies in my
industrial areas and of course no
pollution and actually buildings that
look pretty cool and less cartoony in
that sense it would just be a much more
practical and aesthetic kind of thing in
my city and definitely something that I
would like to have but then again this
this game is
completely moddable so it might always
come I've heard that there might
actually be updates to this and it's
already awesome as is so I'm not going
to complain about that too much it's
just something that I did notice and
speaking of noticing i also noticed that
this area was still red even though i
did redo it so that's gonna actually
need some more work in the future but at
this point i was like no i just spent
like two hours trying to get that area
to not [ __ ] up and i still [ __ ] up I'm
just going to completely ignore that and
going to have all the trucks sitting
there traffic jams because the you know
they are causing this traffic jam to
whatever they can be stuck in it I was
kind of pissed off at all these people
and trying to make this congestion
happening over there but don't worry
don't worry eventually I did finish the
area I did redo it one more time and
right now it's actually not doing that
bad it still got a bit of too much
traffic flow to be good but it's not
really causing any problems anymore so
that's pretty cool as you can see my
highway is getting increasingly
complicated because with every little
thing that I add to it I just want to
have all these on ramps and stuff like
that and the world are practical for one
but I also just kind of like the look of
them so I just decided to overcomplicate
all of my well interchanges and that it
turns into this but at this point I was
like okay um I need bigger population
because as you can see there is quite a
bit of demand for residential well not
quite a bit but this way compared to
industrial and commercial there is and I
was like yeah we might as well build a
suburb of a suburb because you know at
this point the city doesn't really look
like a sober anymore we've got downtown
anyway and stuff like that so I wanted
to expand beyond the highways that I had
right now and I decided that this little
neighborhood was going to be the place
and it's called Houston for no other
reason than that it's called Houston
because i actually do name my
neighborhoods off to a completely random
cities around the world i actually did
not name one of my neighborhood so Sokka
because of weeaboo reasons that actually
kind of didn't happen there is telling
though which is amazing because it's an
amazing city and stuff like that so I
nanaman actually put some Dutch Friday
to I have like a couple like tensed
Dutch cities it in the end but yeah my
neighborhood I just random cities
because I didn't want to spend too much
time coming up with new names but I also
didn't want to have those stupid names
that the game comes with because oh my
they are terrible seriously there and
the most cookie cutter names I have ever
seen and that's not wait that's not a
problem at all but it's just something
that I don't want to have in my city my
city has to have good names otherwise
you know I I wouldn't even want to live
in a neighborhood with a terrible name
no matter how good the neighborhood
maybe and the traffic jams just seemed
to get increasingly terrible at this
place and I was kind of lost with this
industrial area and now you might want
to say well you should place more for
time I'm for lane and six lane roads and
that's something that I do want to avoid
actually and I'm going to talk about
that in a bit just a tiny little bit
right now but I actually might cover it
in a tutorial too and it's kind of a
well-known thing right now but four-lane
roads and six lane roads come with
traffic lights and if there's anything
you'd want to avoid its traffic lights
because even though they are good at
regulating the traffic they are also
very good at making the traffic very
congested and traffic lines are just
kind of annoying in general and if you
can avoid them avoid them and things to
note about this is that two lane roads
don't come with traffic lights two lane
roads that connect to four lane or six
lane roads that are one-sided as in the
two-lane roads are a one way road then
they won't get traffic lights either and
of course highways and on ramps and
stuff like that won't gets rough no wait
highways that connect to normal roads
will get traffic lights but on ramps and
stuff like that one gets recognized
either so those are all things that you
can use to prevent traffic lights from
happening not a big roundabouts because
big roundabout with four or six lane
roads still have traffic lights so I
don't think that is really going to get
you anywhere now of course roundabouts
are pretty sexy though but
yeah so is this Houston area dump I do
kind of like this area but yeah that's
it for this episode so thank you for
watching and in the next episode I'm
going to do something I have no idea
what I'm going to do because I can't be
bothered to look that up but um you'll
see that soon